jour merci à d'être avec nous ce matin
sur rtl france alors que s'est-il passé
hier
bonjour merci de me permettre de parler
de cette cette aventure je veux dire en
fait depuis dix jours maintenant des
jeunes sont mobilisés pour parler de la
loi climat à proximité du parlement avec
des parlementaires qui viennent les
rejoindre sur cette place qui a 50 100 m
2 de l'assemblée nationale je me suis
rendu donc qui hier à 14h15 sur place
étaient déjà présents d'autres collègues
parlementaires de différentes tendances
politiques
et puis en fait au bout de quelques
minutes les gens de la préfecture de
police sont venus signifier aux jeunes
qu'il ne pouvait pas rester là sous des
prétextes fallacieux des prétextes
sanitaires de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
en fait on voit que selon moi c'est le
dévoiement de cet état d'urgence alité à
faire taire toute manifestation pourtant
le conseil d'état bien à bien acté que
cette dernière liberté qui nous reste et
devait être sacralisé donc en fait c'est
faire faire taire toute contestation peu
de paroles aient compris de notre
jeunesse sur des sujets pourtant
essentiel pour moi c'est une dérive ou
maintenant on voit qu'il ya une
utilisation politique de la police et
c'est assez assez assez grave au delà de
mon cas personnel
alors on voit sur les images à vous
portiez vous un masque comme j'imagine
allez les collègues et c'est avec vous à
ce rassemblement
on voit donc ses policiers vous
contrôlez que se passe-t-il ils vous ont
contrôlé verbaliser alors en fait
j'étais là depuis une bonne demi heure
donc tous les fonctionnaires sur place
les fonctionnaires de police ou les
fonctionnaires de la préfecture de paris
savait qui j'étais
nous étions cinq parlementaires au
moment où je vais pour rejoindre
l'hémicycle puisque j'étais en séance
attendu à 15 heures il souhaite m'en
empêcher me disent de rester là et pour
au prétexte de contrôler mon identité à
l'heure où je me soumets un sens sans
discussion aux contrôles d'identité
puisque vous voyez que je présente ma
carte de députés qui fait office de
carte d'identité aux fonctionnaires de
la préfecture mais malgré cela vous
voyez que le fonctionnaire de police
continue à mon poignet a empêchés de
circuler
je veux dire par méconnaissance de ses
limites d'intervention face à un
parlementaire et c'est là que je
m'interroge mois sur maintenant où nous
sommes nous dans quel type d'état est ce
que partout préfet l'allemand maintenant
c'est vie et parce nous sommes dans un
état policier qui empêche les
parlementaires d'aller en séance qui
empêche les manifestations pourtant
autorisé par notre constitution de se
tenir de manière pacifique
tout ça m'inquiète vraiment sûr sur la
dérive de ce pouvoir sur l'utilisation
qui est faite d'un état d'urgence
sanitaire et les forces de police à des
fins politiques est ce que vous le dites
donc on vous a empêché de vous rendre
l'assemblée nationale on la vit sur ces
images se contrôler pour vous c'est
clairement le non respect de l'article
26 de la constitution qui précise
qu'aucun membre du parlement ne peut
être poursuivi recherché arrêté détenu
ou jugé à l'occasion des opinions ou
votes émis par lui dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions
oui s'est précisée par l'antique le 26
mai au delà de ça effectivement nous
parlementaires avant un endroit
particulier et si nous nous sommes étant
effectivement en règle et je les dis je
me suis soumis à ce contrôle puisque
équivalent n'est pas écrit sur moi sur
ma veste que je suis parlementaire même
si j'ai mon écharpe à la main mais je me
suis soumis aux autres d'identité à
partir de ce moment là ils ne peuvent
pas m'empêcher ne doivent pas m'empêcher
d'aller et venir de circuler c'est le
rôle des parlementaires notre notre
fonction est notre mandat est protégée
pour cela et c'est je le dire surtout la
méconnaissance des fonctionnaires de
police ou en tout cas les autres qui
leur sont donnés de ne faire que peu de
cas y compris du respect qu'ils doivent
à la fonction à ce que nous incarnons
dans cette république dans cette
démonstration vous c'est la faute à qui
au préfet d' aider l'allemand ou alors à
ces policiers qui ont qu'ils ont eue qui
ont fait part de deux ailes on le voit
sur ces images en relief et qui manquent
de questions est-ce que c'est
l'ignorance de ce fonctionnaire de
police qui me saoule poursuit de son
carnet de son stylo pour pour essayer de
l'empêcher de rejoindre la séance alors
que il le sait pertinemment que je suis
parlementaire ou est ce que ce sont les
ordres du préfet de police l'allemand
qui souhaite m
un policier en ordre sur sur paris là où
il officie j'allais dire en fait ce sont
les ce sont les deux ce sont les deux
mais je pense que je ne veux pas jeter
l'opprobre sur l'ignorance de ces deux
policiers même si ça me
ça me choque plus que suite à cette
affaire l'autre prud'hommes pour
conclure
écoutez interpellé le préfet l'allemand
parce que ces méthodes sont
insupportables il faut maintenant que
les ordres soient donnés aux policiers
qu'ils fassent leur métier gardiens de
la paix mais pas deux le contrôle de
police politique y compris envers des
parlementaires les collègues qui étaient
là ont été aussi verbaliser alors nous
étions là pacifiquement juste pour
discuter avec des citoyens ce qui est
aussi notre rôle et notre mandat merci
beaucoup pour ce témoignage la surnomme
je rappelle que vous êtes député de la
france info mise de la 3e
circonscription de gironde